surtout quoi
[Musique]
Oh
Je suis très heureux d'être efficace de
porter cette tradition
paysan de naissance
Je suis très heureux d'avoir participé
en cette année 2021
l'année dernière, nous avons également participé, mais
C'était quelque chose comme plus privé pour quoi
quid de la pandémie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce fut une longue nuit de dur labeur mais
avec les meilleures émotions avec le
de meilleures sensations pour tout détecter
le public de Medellín pour l'ensemble
public antioquia colombie et le monde
[Musique]
cet avantage et beaucoup beaucoup parce que je suis
un admirateur avec mon fan
Je ne sais pas pour la parade des silleteros
Je perds des années et des mètres là-bas où
il part mais
[Musique]